REPUBLICANS.
THEN PICKED UP -- IMPORTANT
THING WAS PICKED UP BY
DEMOCRATS OPPOSED TO DONALD
TRUMP.
>> Judge: JOINING US NOW FOR
REACTION IS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR HERMAN CAIN AND
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN MATT
GAETZ.
ALL RIGHT, CONGRESSMAN, I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU FIRST.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS
NEW REPORT BY THE INTEL
COMMITTEE, THE REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY, ACTUALLY?
>> WELL, THIS REPORT IS A
DECISIVE WIN FOR THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE IT
SUPPORTS WHAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN SAYING ALL ALONG.
AND THAT IS THAT RUSSIANS
HAD A GREATER INVOLVEMENT
GLAFTING.
HILLARY CLINTON FUNDED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AUTHORED
DOSSIER THAN THEY EVER HAD
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
STILL AND FRANKLY JUDGE
JEANINE, THIS POINTS OUT THE
NEED TO DISBAND THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE IT'S
BUILT ON A ROTTEN PREMISE
THAT HAS NOW BEEN DISPROVEN
WITH 250 PAGES OF FACT.
>> Judge: ALL RIGHT.
AND HERMAN CAIN TO YOU, THAT
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS
LATEST REPORT FROM THE INTEL
COMMITTEE?
>> MY TAKE, JUDGE JEANINE,
IS THAT HE IS NOT IN HOT
WATER.
HE LIED AND LIED AND LIED.
>> Judge: COMEY?
>> AND NOW WE HAVE TO WAIT
FOR THE PROCESS TO PLAY
ITSELF OUT.
COMEY I'M TALKING ABOUT.
WE NOW HAVE TO WAIT FOR THE
PROCESS TO PLAY ITSELF OUT
FOR HIM TO END UP IN COURT
SUCH THAT A COURT JUDGMENT
PROVES THAT HE LIED AND
TRIED TO KEEP A CLOUD OVER
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
HE AND OTHERS HAVE TRIED TO
KEEP A CLOUD OVER THIS
ADMINISTRATION BUT WITH THIS
REPORT, THE CLOUDS HAVE
PARTED AND NOW WE'RE SEEING
THE TRUTH AND THAT'S WHAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANTED
TO SEE.
>> Judge: YOU KNOW, WHAT'S
INTERESTING, HERMAN, IS THAT
EVEN THOUGH YOU SAY THAT WE
WANT TO SEE THE COURTS GET
INVOLVED.
THE TRUTH IS THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT
WAS SUPPOSED TO COME OUT IN
APRIL REGARDING COMEY.
NOW THEY SAY MAY.
AND PROBABLY EVEN LATER THAN
THAT.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THERE
WAS A REFERENCE BECAUSE HE
LIED TO THE FBI.
I BELIEVE WAS CHAIRMAN
GRASSLEY'S COMMITTEE WHO
MADE A CRIMINAL REFERRAL TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
MONTHS AND MONTHS AGO,
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED.
WE KNEW MCCABE LIED OVER
MORE THAN SEVERAL MONTHS
AGO.
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING
TO TAKE?
I THINK THEY ARE
SLOW-WALKING THE DOCUMENTS
WE DON'T HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
SO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GET
PAST 2018, CHANGE THE HOUSE.
>> I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
YOU.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SLOW-WALK
THIS CLOUD.
SLOW WALK THESE
INVESTIGATIONS.
SUCH THAT THEY GET THROUGH
NOVEMBER 2018.
BUT HERE'S THE THING, JUDGE
JEANINE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
INCLUDING SOME DEMOCRATS,
ARE NOT STUPID.
WE HAVE HAD ENOUGH EVIDENCE
COME OUT EVEN THROUGH THE
MEDIA THAT SAYS HE HAS LIED
AND DISCREDITED HIMSELF AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SWALLOW
THE GULLABLE LIES THAT THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE LIBERALS
ARE TRYING TO PUSH ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO SLOW
WALK THIS ONE.
BECAUSE WHEN AN AG REPORT
COMES OUT.
IT'S GOING TO BE THE ICING
ON THE CAKE.
>> CONGRESSMAN GATES YOU
ENDED BY SAYING YOUR LAST
COMMENT THAT IT'S TIME FOR
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER'S GROUP TO BE
DISBANDED.
BUT, TODAY, OR YESTERDAY, I
BELIEVE IT WAS CHAIRMAN
GRASSLEY OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY WHO LET A BILL OUT
OF COMMITTEE SUPPORTED BY A
FEW REPUBLICANS LIKE LINDSEY
GRAHAM SAYING THEY ARE GOING
TO BLOCK THE PRESIDENT FROM
FIRING MUELLER AND
DISBANDING THE COMMISSION.
I MEAN, ON THE ONE HAND WE
HAVE YOU SAYING ONE THING
AND GRASSLEY SAYING ANOTHER.
WHY IS GRASSLEY WASTING HIS
TIME WITH THIS KIND OF A
BILL.
>> WELL, SENATOR GRASSLEY
HAS DONE A LOT TO CONTRIBUTE
TO OUR INVESTIGATION OF THE